just in time for Christmas we have got
the feel-goods story of the year
Oberlin College has finally forked over
36 million dollars to Gibson's Bakery a
local shop that the college tried to
destroy with a baseless charge of racism
back in 2016. a lot of people don't
remember this I actually wrote about it
in my book speechless controlling words
controlling Minds six years ago there we
go six years ago a black Oberlin College
undergrad named Jonathan Aladdin tried
to pass a fake ID at Gibson's to buy a
bottle of wine
Alan Gibson who's a son and Grandson of
the owners rejected the fake ID and
noticed that the student had hidden two
other bottles in his coat at which point
Gibson said he was calling the cops and
he raised his phone to take a picture of
the would-be thief the student then
smacked Gibson's phone away smacked the
guy in the face and assaulted the store
owner David Gibson when Gibson chased
the student out of the store a couple
other students joined in
by the time the cops got there all three
students had Gibson on the ground and
were punching and kicking him
this seems like an open and shut case
right you throw the criminal kids in
prison and you make them apologize to
the store owner that they tried to Rob
but we're not talking about a normal
community
we're talking about Oberlin College and
we're talking about a case of a white
shop owner and black thieves which meant
that the students had to be in the right
and the shop owner had to be in the
wrong facts be damned the shop had to be
destroyed What followed was a
college-led boycott and smear campaign
against Gibsons the assistant dean of
students texted the dean of students and
vice president of the school quote I
hope we Reign fire and brimstone on that
store
which they did
but what the school was not counting on
was that Gibson's Bakery would fight
back Alan Gibson was 89 years old
he had dedicated his life to the
business he knew that he was not going
to live for very long after that 89 is
pretty old and he did in fact die before
the litigation was completed
before the college paid up but Gibson
refused to lay down
and die being falsely branded a racist
Gibson took Oberlin to court Gibson won
so Oberlin appealed
the ninth circuit rejected the appeal
Oberlin tried to take it up to the
Supreme Court of Ohio in a 4-3 decision
so very very close elections matter the
Supreme Court refused to take up the
case finally in September of this year
Oberlin agreed to pay up what it owed
and just last week it finally paid to
the tune of 36 and a half million
dollars
absolutely beautiful I hope Alan Gibson
is looking down from heaven and smiling
and I hope conservatives are looking up
right now and taking notes the woke
monsters who want to ruin our lives will
not give up until we hit them where it
hurts and that means conservatives need
to get a lot more comfortable suing
defamers like this into Oblivion I'm
Michael Knowles this the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Old School
it's been a while since we've had old
school does a top comment says Trump's
huge announcement is cringe as all get
out but it has upset the left for that
reason and that reason alone I like it
he lives rent free in their sheep heads
a pretty blunt way to put it but it's
true and it does sum up a lot of the way
that I still feel about Trump he he does
things he's always done things where I
think I really don't agree with that I
think that's a bad move the first step
act I think that's a bad move hiring
this guy hiring that lady Ah that's a
bad move this that but
the libs hate his guts and so that is a
good indicator that he's doing something
right
okay it's true it's true that's and when
I try to form my opinion about these
things I don't just try to look at the
politics I don't even just try to look
at the cultural context I try to look at
the the most important context which is
the religious context okay as Cardinal
Manning put it all human conflict
ultimately is theological that's why you
got to know your Bible it's why you've
got to check out Bible in a year with
father Mike Schmitz right now head on
over to ascensionpress.com if you are
someone who has always wanted to read
and understand the Bible but you're not
sure where to start then you got to
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible in ear podcast
is currently the most popular religion
podcast in the United States a lot of
people ask me Michael you're a podcaster
you have a popular show what podcasts do
you listen to the only podcast that I
reliably listen to is Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmitz I absolutely
adore it it's hit the number one spot in
apple it's a really
bite-sized commentary you know only
about 20 minutes or so per episode they
go through the whole Bible and you get
great commentary with father Mike
Schmitz father Mike Schmitz was one of
the first guests on this show years ago
when it started go check it out right
now you can follow along uh in your
Ascension press Bible you can listen in
your car which is what I do if you want
to start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible is your go to
ascensionpress.com Knowles to download
the reading plan for free that is
ascensionpress.com Knowles to download
the reading plan for free
there's some more good news for
conservatives here in the culture
so really great news with the Gibson's
Bakery Story and I know people haven't
tracked the story all that closely even
though when I first saw it it really it
left such an impression on me I featured
it in my book because I thought it was
just such a a perfect encapsulation of
how politically correct culture and how
the manipulation of language can just
completely warp people's perceptions of
reality
but but we won
I say we I'm referring to we as Gibson's
Bakery I'm referring to we as those of
us who resist the woke mob I'm referring
to we as those of us who who don't want
to just have people's lives destroyed
with baseless charges of racism you
utter the magic phrase racism or sexism
or whatever and then you can just
destroy a man's life it's like saying
Abracadabra okay and we've got to stand
against that so that's a big win I think
for conservatives we just got another
big win
PornHub has been banned from YouTube
now I didn't know PornHub was on YouTube
I assumed PornHub just has porn
everywhere and YouTube does not allow
porn but I guess PornHub had a YouTube
channel where it was relatively within
the limits Allowed by YouTube even
though it's kind of Saucy and obviously
the point was just to direct people over
to the PornHub website
YouTube says no more they banned the
account which had almost a million
followers after repeated violations this
comes after meta slash Instagram that is
what owns Facebook
banned PornHub this after tick tock
banned PornHub this after Visa
Mastercard Roku Comcast Unilever Kraft
Heinz at craft Heinz I don't know what
PornHub can't get ketchup anymore I
guess not and PayPal also have cut ties
with PornHub
great great news according to YouTube
spokesman Jack Malon fun review We
terminated the channel following
multiple violations of our community
guidelines we enforce our policies
equally for everyone and channels that
repeatedly violate or are dedicated to
violative content or terminated so you
can tell YouTube's trying to say there
there was no targeting of PornHub in
particular they we just treat everyone
exactly the same we all know that isn't
true
we all know big Tech plays favorites we
we know that for years they've targeted
conservatives on all of these platforms
but okay here they're targeting the libs
they're targeting PornHub that's a very
good thing I I wish we lived in a
culture where these the YouTube
spokesman could be honest and say no you
know we finally realized that this
company which is trafficking in misery
and everyone from the the abused
girlfriends and human trafficking
victims who are put in their videos all
the way up to the professionals who have
an agent who go to big fancy sets in the
valley and shoot porn all of these
people have been abused okay all of
these people are being exploited to to
excite the lusts of men and plunge our
culture into degradation and we're not
going to do it anymore and yes we are
targeting them and it's a damn right
thing that we're targeting them I wish
we could live in that culture we're not
quite there yet so you get this mealy
mouth well you know actually we're just
applying the rules fairly and okay
whatever fine get rid of PornHub just
get rid of it just nuke it PornHub has
no no right to exist PornHub is bad for
everybody
bad for the performers bad for the
consumers bad for the the flourishing of
civilized society just nuke it okay
and I know I can already hear in the
distance the Rumblings of
the kind of
libertarian I don't even I hate to even
call it libertarian the sort of very
shallow licentious argument where people
say
well you know if we ban PornHub next
thing you know people are going to be
banning the Bible First of all they
already banned the Bible you're not
allowed to teach the Bible in schools
all right and you are actually allowed
to teach pornography in schools now so
amazing how the culture is flipped but
no if you we can tell the difference
between porn and the Bible okay we can
tell the difference between as Justice
Potter Stewart famously observed and he
was right even though he gets mocked for
it
when it comes to obscenity and
pornography you actually can know it
when you see it
and we should be able to say yeah we
know what this stuff is we can tell the
difference between art and porn and
we're going to ban the porn
now unfortunately
despite this big win The Establishment
is still working hard to defend the
worst aspects of the sexual Revolution
you saw this just in the last week when
the FBI
arrested two more pro-life Advocates
this this has been happening for a while
now
it hasn't made the news all that much
one because the establishment media
suppresses the story but also because it
it just happens so regularly that it
doesn't end up being news oh yep the FBI
went in and targeted more pro-lifers
pro-lifers go in with hidden cameras
this was years ago they go in with
hidden cameras my friend David Delight
in the Center for Medical progress they
expose Planned Parenthood of breaking
the law selling baby body parts to the
highest bidder
and what happens
the powers that be prosecute
the investigative journalists who expose
the story they don't go after Planned
Parenthood they go after the pro-lifers
what happens when in Washington DC
you've got pro-life advocates
discover horrible abuses at abortion
Mills babies being killed after birth
and and late term abortions and all the
rest of it they uncover this they have
they have evidence of it in the baby's
bodies what happens the powers that be
they go after the pro-lifers and so now
we've got two more pro-lifers arrested
for violating the face law
the face law is the freedom of access to
Clinic entrances Act
they apparently violated the face law up
in New York by unlawfully blocking
access to abortion Mills
in multiple States over the years
now the question that I have is one I
hope these guys have good lawyers I hope
that there they have access to to Legal
resources from the pro-life movement
which is pretty well funded because
people like you listening to the show
right now support it because we realize
what a moral atrocity abortion is my
question is this
why don't I hear any Republican
lawmakers
pushing to overturn the Absurd and evil
face law why is it that the pro-lifers
keep getting plucked off because of this
ridiculous federal law saying that
people have a right to access abortion
Mills this law passed during the Clinton
administration
and I don't hear Republican lawmakers
overturning that law so that the feds
have a tougher time going after the
pro-lifers where are the Republican
lawmakers on this issue
we need we need Republicans to be
stronger when you want to be stronger
you got to check out Echelon Fitness
right now text Knowles to 81 81.81 I
have been working too hard this year and
not working out enough I want to get in
shape I don't have time to get to the
gym that's why Echelon Fitness brings
the gym to my home Echelon Fitness is
the affordable way to get workout
equipment a workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort and privacy of your own home
Echelon Fitness is connected app
provides thousands of Live And on-demand
classes with great music to keep you
moving you can work at any time day or
night their full range of affordable
workout equipment includes stationary
bikes smart rowers Lake Fitness screens
and an auto folding treadmill these are
all connected to the echelon fitness app
round-the-clock classes including full
body workout programs will keep you
coming back one membership covers a
family of five sweet little Elisa and I
absolutely adore Echelon for for a
limited time our audience can get a free
bike or rowing machine with a 24-month
membership this is a crazy deal I have
the bike it's very very high quality to
get your free bike or rower text Knowles
kwles to 81 8181 that is Knolls to
8181.81 to claim your free bike or
rowing machine text Knowles to 81 8181
message and data rates may apply see
terms for details we got to get rid of
this face law this is what the feds use
as an excuse to go after the pro-lifers
and the FEDS will still try to go after
the pro-lifers even if you got rid of
the law it would just be much harder to
do it don't give our political opponents
the pretext to prosecute us what does
the face law do
was passed in 1994 signed by Clinton it
prohibits the use of physical Force
threat of physical force or physical
obstruction to intentionally injure
intimidate interfere with or attempt to
injure intimidate or interfere with any
person who's obtaining an abortion
that's number one two it prohibits the
use of fiscal Force threat physical
force or physical obstruction to
intentionally endure intimidate
interfere with or attempt to injure
intimidate or interfere with any person
who is exercising or trying to exercise
their First Amendment right of religious
freedom at a place of religious worship
and three it prohibits the intentional
damage or destruction of a reproductive
Health Care Facility or a place of
worship first of all it's it's amazing
how honest that law is
equating abortion Mills with churches
it's not honest in the sense that the
two are not equivalent they're quite the
opposite but the law is honest in that
they recognize okay conservatives have
churches and synagogues and and mosques
I guess
liberals have abortion Mills
when conservatives want to worship they
they go and they get on their knees and
they pray to God when liberals want to
worship their deity they murder babies
what God are they worshiping
which which God God or Gods which is it
ball is it moloch is the the Devil
Himself who they're worshiping by
sacrificing babies because we've seen
that as a recurrent theme throughout all
of human history
so um amazing honesty there and when you
see that
you realize okay well that can't be
permitted now now you might look at the
law and say okay well I don't think
people should be able to use physical
force or you know even to stop an evil
such as abortion I don't think that
pro-lifers should be able to go there
with baseball bats and start clubbing
the the crazy pro-life activists yeah
right of course not we're not saying
that we should have vigilantism or
anything like that
but you see how broad this law is anyone
who in any way interferes with or
physically what does that mean you're
gonna have a little old nun praying the
rosary outside of the abortion Mill and
and someone could claim as reasonably as
they claim with any of these cases well
she's obstructing access
she's got to go three blocks away it's
just absurd just repeal the whole law
it's an evil law passed by a terrible
president and uh the conservatives need
to to do it we've already won on Roe v
Wade okay we overruled Roe v Wade Dobbs
did it that's great stuff now in a post
Dobbs future what is the pro-life
movement going to do repeal this stupid
law
speaking of
babies
Nick Cannon
one of the most
fertile I guess you wouldn't call him
fertile you'd call him prolific maybe
you'd call him very active and busy
celebrities out there
he's got something like 10 kids with
almost as many babies mama is it baby
mamas or baby's mama is it like a
attorney's General I don't know I'm not
totally familiar with that culture
anyway Nick Cannon is discussing how
complicated it is to go buy Christmas
presents
it's almost the holidays and thanks to
me the world now has 8 billion people
but my job's not done it's time to do
some online Christmas shopping and based
off the baby mama the kid ratio we got a
whole hell of a lot of gifts to buy
let's go
[Music]
and it started off My adorable and
jovial Offspring gave me a list
Daddy's got this it's gonna be a merry
Christmas I didn't get none of this
stuff when I was a kid no my daddy got
me a stick used to call me stick candy
Matthew Mark Luke and John are those
books in the Bible more kid names no I
can't afford the whole Lakers maybe one
of them I could probably purchase one
Laker all these damn gifts y'all just
don't want to go to college 12 ps5s
how about I give you a p two and a half
I think I got carpal tunnel hahaha get
it he's got a ton of kids with a bunch
of different women and so he's got to
buy all these Christmas presents for
them hahaha
producer Danny who is much more up on
pop culture than I am informs me it's
not that Nick Cannon has upwards of 10
kids Danny seems to think that he's got
11 going on 12 kids whatever the number
is Nick Cannon in a more serious
interview said quote
being a father of multiple kids it's
always the biggest guilt on me is that I
don't get to spend enough time with all
my children one because I'm constantly
working and two because I'm just spread
thin
a lot of people knock Nick Cannon
because he goes around and impregnates
all of these women and isn't married to
them and doesn't form a stable family
and is very irresponsible the reason I
don't go after Nick Cannon as hard as
some people do is I always think
at least he doesn't kill the kids
it's sad that that is the bar in our
society
but our society murders 850 000 babies a
year so if you don't kill your kids
you are already starting at a higher
place than that Baseline in our culture
and I genuinely give Nick Cannon credit
for that
now of course we want to raise our
standards a little bit and the reason
the Nick Cannon feels guilt is because
he's doing something that is shameful
he is intentionally depriving children
of a stable family okay
you are supposed to have children
within the context of marriage marriage
is the lifelong Union the Perpetual
Union of a man and a woman of a husband
and a wife for the good of the spouses
and the sake of the generation and
education of children lots of people
this doesn't totally work out or they
make mistakes and they later come to
repent it and I get it it's a very
Fallen World people have Blended
families and all these sorts of things
but
repenting and trying to make the best of
a bad situation in a fallen world is
very different from intentionally
creating the sort of chaotic and
disordered circumstances that will
that will continue to spread in that
Fallen World okay
and Nick Cannon seems to be very much in
the latter category it's not just that
Nick Cannon had a wild kind of early
life and now he's settling down with a
family and trying to do right by the
rest of his kids that he had wronged
it's the app is still knocking up all of
these different women and he's telling
jokes about it and it reminds me of a
line from Chesterton
Chesterton pointed out that the problem
of the modern world is not that it's too
evil but that it's too good
except it's it's good in a way not where
the virtues all work together to give
you a flourishing Society it's good in
the sense that people take one virtue
and they just pursue that relentlessly
and they ignore all of the other virtues
that the virtues have been separated and
they're wandering around aimlessly and
recklessly so Nick Cannon as I gave him
credit at the top he's not killing his
kids he recognizes that it's a good
thing to have kids and it is a lot of
Elites in our society don't realize that
people like Bill Gates people especially
Bill Gates because he's obsessed with
trying to reduce the number of kids that
people have people like our our whole
contraceptive mentality and our abortive
mentality and the Looney Tunes at the
world economic Forum in the U.N
trying to push abortion and
contraception and deal with
overpopulation that supposed problem
it's a it's a nonsense of course Elon
Musk points out rightly that the world
actually has an underpopulation problem
but that's a topic for another time so
Nick Cannon gets it he gets that it's
good be fruitful and multiply man is
made in the image and likeness of God it
is a good thing to have kids
but he has divorced that virtuous
insight
from all the other virtues which is it's
good to have families children have a
right to their natural father and mother
join together in marriage children have
a right to be conceived in the conjugal
act within the context of marriage
Nick Cannon has has divorced the the
good Insight from all of the contexts
surrounding so he he really ought to
correct himself we all really ought to
correct ourselves as well and we can
recognize the right especially in this
crazy world I I I'm reminded of a book
by Aleister McIntyre it's called after
virtue where he describes our current
moral situation as a people in this post
nuclear kind of apocalyptic world the
whole civilization all of human
knowledge has been blown up and they
find kind of scraps of a science
textbook you know one equation here one
little commentary on physics here and
from that we've got to piece back
together the whole of human scientific
knowledge that's where that's where we
are right now when it comes to morality
and ethics
okay Nick Cannon it's right be fruitful
and multiply well what what does that
mean man is made in the image of
likeness of God great what does that
mean what does that mean for your family
I mean stop going out and trying to find
new baby's mama and
raise your raise your family and settle
down and get married and
within that context have more kids it
sounds great when you want to be more
virtuous you got to check out Exodus 90.
right now go to exodus90.com Knowles men
stop Doom scrolling it is time to put
that phone down stop Doom scrolling it's
time to finally gain that higher quality
of life that you know you're missing out
on if this sounds like something that
you are interested in then on January
9th join thousands of men to embark on a
90-day journey together in search of a
better life Exodus 90 was built to help
men enjoy the freedom of becoming who
they were truly meant to be Exodus 90
guides you in removing the attachments
that are holding you back from a better
life and it actually works independent
research shows that Exodus 90 men report
considerable shifts after 90 days
including stronger satisfaction in their
marriages more meaningful prayer lives
and dramatic decreases in time spent on
their phones for the past seven years
Exodus has helped more than sixty
thousand men build a road map for living
with virtue in a culture that offers far
too many opportunities for
self-destruction is it time for your
Exodus we all start January 9th find
resources to prepare for Exodus at
exodus90.com Knowles that is
exodus90.com Knowles
speaking of people who have lots of
children
speaking speaking of Elon Musk
specifically
Elon Musk has been a whirlwind in the
last couple of weeks it's very hard to
keep up with him
last night Elon Musk said that he might
step down as CEO of Twitter he would let
the people decide he said he would abide
by the results of a poll should he
remain at the head of Twitter and the
the poll said he should not remain at
the head of Twitter which is horrible I
wish Elon Musk would remain at the head
of Twitter because he's done a very good
job but this popular appeal
follows a lot of other popular appeals
that Elon Musk has made Elon Musk just a
few nights ago when I was on the Tim
Poole show out in the middle of the
woods outside Washington Elon Musk
banned a bunch of liberal journalists
which I thought was awesome Tim broke
the news to me on the show I said this
is great I'm so happy and then
Elon reversed it and unbanned them
the journalists quote unquote
journalists they're just liberal
activists had been doxing Elon Musk
putting his family at risk so he banned
them but then he said okay I'll abide by
the results of the poll if
you think I should unban them they only
have a seven day suspension but I'll
unban them if you want me to and then
the people said unban them and then he
unbanned them He restored the accounts
of CNN's Donnie O'Sullivan New York
Times Tech reporter Ryan Mack wapa
reporter Drew Harwell Aaron rupparo one
of the worst or the worst Nationals Matt
binder Bender he was also allowed back
and and the principle that Elon has
articulated during this whole thing is
four words
works properly Vox day the voice of the
people is the voice of God he's used
that phrase specifically
vox populi Vox day and it's a cute
phrase and it's been used a lot
especially in the last 300 or so years
but the thing we got to remember is
it's not true
in fact the earliest appearance of the
phrase
is from a deacon named alqueen who wrote
this at the end of the 8th Century I
think it was 798 or thereabouts wrote it
in a warning to Charlemagne and he said
you got to resist this idea this is a
terrible dangerous idea he said those
people should not be listened to who
keep saying the voice of the people is
the voice of God since the riotousness
of the crowd is always very close to
Madness now the problem is
the the phrase which was initially used
to mock the idea that the voice of the
people is the voice of God later on in
the 14th century and especially after
the early 18th century came to be used
to affirm the principle that the voice
of the people is the voice of God we
even we conservatives in America
sometimes appeal to this idea when we're
feeling particularly populist and
Democratic
but it is not true more often than not
it is the opposite of true do you
remember what the mob did to Socrates
it's Christmas time do you remember what
the mob did to our Lord Jesus Christ
remember was that the voice of the
people being the voice of God
furthermore when you recognize that God
has two distinct Wills God's perfect
will and God's permissive will God's
perfect will being what God
really wants for all of us and God's
permissive will it within the context of
human Free Will turning bad things to
good this is when we say the fall of Man
in a way could be viewed as a good thing
it was bad in and of itself but a happy
fault that one for us so great So
Glorious a redeemer uh God the Father
allowing the uh passion and crucifixion
of his son Jesus
bad thing in itself
certainly seems very bad and wicked and
unjust and evil except that God has
overcome the evil of this world
that the darkness has not overcome the
light and so three days after the
crucifixion on the third day Christ
rises again conquers death and uh now
now we all celebrated Easter so when you
recognize that there's a difference
between those two things then the voice
of the people can advocate for very
wicked things indeed
it's not a conservative idea to to say
vox populi Vox day
Elon Musk though as a kind of agent of
chaos allowed this principle and then
when he reinstated the journalists the
journals go into a Twitter chat and they
all start whining about Elon Musk and
then Elon Musk joins the Twitter chat
and gives them a piece of his mind
as I'm sure everyone who's been
dachshund uh would agree you know
showing real-time information about
somebody's location is inappropriate and
I think everyone on this quote would not
like that to be done for them and and
there's not going to be any distinction
in the future between journalists
they're both journalists and and regular
people everyone's going to be treated
the same they're not special because
you're a journalist there's you're just
you're a Twitter you're just you're a
citizen
um
so
uh no special treatment
um docs you do actually get suspended
and a story
you're not that special journows I know
this is the the worst phrase you've ever
heard in your life because you believe
you work at CNN you work at MSNBC you
tell yourself
you are the fourth estate the Intrepid
courageous reporter speaking truth to
power
they're not of course they are doing the
bidding of power the most powerful
interests in the whole country are
paying their bills they say we're so
special we're standing up
and Elon says you're not special but I
have a blue check mark and now everybody
gets a blue check mark no I'm special
You Can't Ban me Elon yes I can you dox
me you docks my family
I'm going to ban you I wish he had
banned them more
it was a good thing my only complaint
about the Elon Musk incident
is that he did not ban them more I'll be
speaking on this more a little bit later
today at TP USA I'm flying out to
Phoenix right after my show uh to
America Fest very very excited that I
was able to to make it to that so so we
will not be having a member segment
today we got great member segment coming
the rest of the week but I had to fly
out there had to go celebrate some of
the wins that we're getting right now
and had to make my plea before the
people to say no we need Elon we need
Elon to ban more of the liberal
journalists it's actually a great thing
but the the liberal journals the fence
sitters the the so-called moderates and
centrists and I don't think they're
really all that moderate of Centrist
they don't really get it Barry Weiss
who has who who is a liberal she's a
liberal journalist but because she has
in any way uh broken ranks with the far
left the conservatives all go Gaga they
say wow she's one of us I don't I don't
think she's one of us I'd like some of
her work but I'm sure we all share very
different premises about the world and
Barry Weiss lets that be known every
once in a while so Elon Musk gave the
Twitter files to expose the corruption
at Twitter under the previous ownership
two berry wise and and the other
journalist Matt taibi similar kind of
cloth you know lit liberal journalist
who sometimes breaks ranks but Barry
Weiss went off on Elon about this she
said
the old regime at Twitter governed by
its own whims and biases and it sure
looks like the new regime has the same
problem I oppose it in both cases
and I think those journalists who are
reporting on a story of public
importance should be reinstated
nope
no no that isn't true though there are
many people who would even call
themselves conservatives who agree with
Barry Weiss's point but nevertheless
it's wrong I I had this debate on Tim
cast the other night it was mostly a
debate between me and Luke on the show
Luke representing much more of the
libertarian position I was representing
much more at the conservative position
the libertarian position and the liberal
Barry Weiss position is this
anytime
anyone wields power within the Public
Square to set standards and norms and to
censor I know we're not allowed to use
the c word to censor a certain speech
that is always equally bad no matter
who's doing it
we shouldn't tolerate it
now this is a utopian and Preposterous
position because we all agree that
certain things should be banned from the
Public Square we all agree child
pornography should be banned from the
Public Square we all agree well I think
we all agree that threats should be
banned fraud should be I think we all
agree on that
all none of that type of speech has has
ever been considered protected by the
first amendment obscenity should
obscenity be banned I certainly think so
according to the laws on our books
obscenity should be banned but in recent
years legal protections
for the community against obscenity have
broken down because of activist judges
but I think that should be banned we all
agree certain things should be censored
how about the n-word that's a good
example of a taboo in our culture should
do we think that the n-word should be
permitted and used all over social media
no one really thinks that and and it
wouldn't be tolerated
okay now what about
when we start getting into
more controversial issues
what about let's talk about uh
transgenderism
according to the old regime at Twitter
you were not allowed to call a man who
thinks that he's a woman a man that
could get you banned that was called
misgendering if you referred to Richard
Levine who's the man who wears the skirt
and he he's the assistant Health
secretary because we're living in clown
world if you refer to him as Richard or
he that could have gotten you banned
under the old Twitter regime
now today if you dox Elon Musk and his
family
that could get you banned under the new
Twitter regime I guess as a matter of
procedure
there's a similarity because certain
speech can get you banned but that's
where the similarities end okay those
are completely different uses of speech
and it is it is not the same thing
to to say we will ban you for telling
the truth
and and stating an important fact namely
that men who pretend to be women are
actually men
versus we're going to ban you for
endangering a man's life and behaving
and I would go further than that I think
there's plenty of speech that we can
police and discourage that has always
been true yeah politically political
correctness is a speech code
so is chivalry
so is being a gentleman okay it's not
the same well
if we wield political power why then
we'll be the same as the Liberals
no we won't
because while there can be similarities
with process and procedure similarities
in substance matter too I was having
this debate on timcast
if you Michael if you
encourage good things
and ban bad things
why then you're no different from the
left which is which encourages bad
things and bans good things no good and
bad are not the same
but Michael the leftists think that
they're right right but they're wrong
but how do you know what's right and
wrong because we just do that's what
ultimately this debate on Tim Cass broke
down to is I asked Luke I said Luke you
telling me we can't know the difference
between good and bad right and wrong he
says no we can't it's just arbitrary I
said okay
do you think
do you think it's better to bake a pie
for a widow or to kick a baby in the
head
and which is and he said well I'm not
answering that's a ridiculous question
it's not a ridiculous question it's a
very simple that's a hypothetical it's
not a hypothetical I'm not asking him a
hypothetical question which relies on
conditional statements I'm asking him a
question in the present in the Here and
Now is it better to bake a pie for a
widow or to kick a baby in the head
we all know that it's better to kick the
bit no I'm joking we all know it's
better to bake the pie for the Widow so
if we all know that then that means that
we can come to certain conclusions about
what is good and what is bad and we can
act on those conclusions that's what
self-government is
speaking of good holy things the holy
days are here they're officially here
everybody many of you are already daily
wire Plus members
you get to enjoy the great content that
we have released this year such as what
is a woman Terror on the Prairie and the
greatest lie ever sold if you have not
been able to enjoy it because you're not
a member then take advantage of our 30
holiday sale this also applies to gift
memberships so do not miss this
opportunity to get everyone on your list
and annual gift membership from daily
wire plus with code holiday at checkout
since joining DIY plus Jordan Peterson
has just ramped up his already busy
schedule we have been reaping the
rewards earlier this year Jordan and our
production team went to DC to film a
beautiful and engaging documentary on
the Museum of the Bible called logos and
literacy in it Jordan meets with
historians theologians and philosophers
to discuss the history of the Bible and
its influence on the world the only way
you can watch it is if you were a daily
wire plus member so sign up today use
code holiday at checkout get 30 off your
annual daily wire plus membership at
dailywire.com Knowles that is
dailywire.com Knowles today
the Liberals pretend to trust people
they pretend to believe in that slogan
vox populi Vox day but they do not
actually trust people you see this very
clearly with what the house Dems are
trying to do right now
they're trying to prevent Trump from
running again
dozens of house Democrats are lining up
behind legislation put forward by
representative David siciline that would
ban Donald Trump from running for
president again
this bill will not work it would get
absolutely shredded in court but it's
instructive because it shows you how
afraid the house Democrats are of trump
even still even when they pretend we
don't care Trump's a loser I we hope
he's on the ticket because he's going to
get well
they're clearly not all that confident
because they're trying to pass
legislation that would bar him from ever
appearing on a ballot why because they
know that if the guy's on a ballot
there's a fair chance he becomes
president again so what they're trying
to do is use section three of the 14th
Amendment to boot him from running again
uh because they they're accusing Trump
of orchestrating and Insurrection on
January 6th John John worry six the very
worst day in the history of right you
know it's because it was an Insurrection
except
that none of the people involved in
January 6th have been charged with
inciting or participating in an
insurrection
they've been charged with disorderly
conduct
they've been charged with vandalism
no one has been charged with
insurrection
Trump has not been convicted of you know
charged with Insurrection none of it
it's all totally bogus
but this is
having the opposite effect I think of
what the house stems were going for
it is to me making the strongest
argument for Trump 2024.
I think I have been more fair
than
pretty much any other conservative in
public life when it comes to the 2024
presidential race there are a lot of
people
who say I will never
Veer from Donald Trump Do or Die ride or
die I am 100 with him I will not
consider any other candidates period
there are a lot of people who say that
no generally not so much in the media
space in the media space what you're
hearing from is pretty much every single
conservative talking head saying I that
they're all in for Ron DeSantis and you
know fair enough Rhonda Sanchez has done
a fabulous job as governor of Florida
but they they they're basically
campaigning for Ron DeSantis already and
here I am alone crying out saying hey
everybody
the thing is two years out
hey everybody we don't actually need to
pick a nominee two years out there's
something called a primary process you
can kind of let that play out
Rhonda Sanders even hasn't even said
he's running yet for President right
I've been I've been yelling this
basically into the void
I've tried to be very very fair I love
Donald Trump he is the greatest
president of my lifetime I would happily
vote for him again
if he were the nominee I like Ron
DeSantis I don't know him very well I'm
very impressed by what he's done in
Florida I would happily vote for Ron
DeSantis assuming assuming some terrible
thing doesn't come out in the primary
process I would happily vote for Ron
DeSantis if he were the nominee
I think there are plenty of other good
candidates actually who maybe haven't
even gotten into the race yet and I
would happily vote for many of them if
they were the nominee
one of the best arguments though for
Trump in particular over all the other
guys
is the libs I think still hate him the
most
and I don't want to just base my whole
political life over who the libs hate
the most but it is a pretty good rule of
thumb okay there's a pretty good
heuristic to be able to look out and say
okay here's a gut check here
who do the libs consider to be the
biggest threat who are they working the
hardest to stop from taking office again
maybe it's because that guy is actually
challenging the system not perfectly not
with everything I want but they seem to
fear Him the most okay that's a good
argument who knows it might change maybe
they'll start going after DeSantis more
maybe they'll start going after some
other guy more but right now
it's one of the best Arguments for Trump
Another good argument for Trump
he's still very popular
he is and you don't want to believe it
but he is
I know there's some of you out there not
all some of you do want to believe it
but there's some of you out there that
say we've had enough of trump well let's
move on from Trump I'm just telling you
he's still very popular
and the proof of this is what we were
joking about at the end of last week
do you remember Trump said I've got a
huge announcement major major
announcement
America needs a superhero this is going
to be huge and then what's the announce
he announces that he's selling
digital trading cards so they're not
even physical they're digital trading
cards with his face
as a bunch of different superheroes and
in one he's a football player and one
he's an astronaut really really weird
and I thought okay this is funny I'm I
am laughing about this I I wish it were
tied to something a little more
substantive but okay well I'm here to
tell you
the trading cards sold out within hours
and you might say Michael
how does a computer image sell out
do the people know instead of paying a
hundred dollars for a digital image do
they know you could just right click to
save them in jazz and then you have it
on your no this is an nft what is an nft
I don't even really know I did sell one
once though and it's a it's a unique
token though
they had a limited number of these they
only had 45
000 of these cards pretty substantial
number they sold out almost immediately
14 000 people bought up all of the cards
and this is the key
the people bought you might just say
Okay 14 000 speculators went out and
bought up an asset
and the price did initially drop after
they bought them up so they say okay
there it is this is worthless but then
the price went back up
and the price has actually only been
really increasing since then
which means that
not only the people not only the public
opinion polls but the market
still believes that Trump is a valuable
asset that Trump is a viable commodity
that is why
Democrats are trying to kill his
campaign in the Cradle
because
even though they're putting out a lot of
press and a lot of surveys a lot of
headlines Trump's over he's done he's
totally finished he's going nowhere they
don't totally believe that
they realize that in politics where
there's life There's Hope
and they realize well you know certain
public opinion polls telling me that
Trump's popular you know he did win the
presidency once already
the market telling me Trump actually
he's not totally totally out
[Music]
and so they're they're trying through
corruption
to destroy his campaign now speaking of
democrat corruption the White House will
not answer
basic questions about their own
corruption and their ties to very
corrupt people like Sam bangman freed
who ran the FTX scam who was the second
biggest donor to Democrats in 2022.
Karine Jean-Pierre was just asked by
Zeke Miller White House reporter hey is
Biden going to give back all that money
that he got from that fraudster over
there here's the answer from the White
House
the president received campaign
donations uh campaign donation for him
many prominent Democrats and some
Republicans did as well but will the
president return that donation does he
call on all politicians who got the
campaign donations that may have come
from customer money to return those
funds so look I'm covered here by the
Hatch Act limited on what I can say and
anything that's connected to political
contributions uh from here I I would
have to refer you to the DNC I'm asking
the president's opinion no but you know
does he want those people who no you
asked me two questions you asked me
about will he return the donations and
then you asked me about his opinion I'm
answering the first part which is I'm
covered by the Hatch Act from here I'm
limited to what I can say and I just
can't talk to political contributions or
anything related to that I cannot speak
about it from here his opinion though I
I just is just cannot speak to this uh
from here even his opinion even in his
thoughts about the contributions
donations I cannot speak from it from
about that from here
I am covered by the hijack which I'm
happy to say over and over again because
we believe in the rule of law here
so her answer is totally Bogus the Hatch
Act exists to to root out political
corruption and and stop people who have
government offices from using those
government offices to conduct campaign
work to extort money out of people to
trade government positions for money to
trade favors that's what it's for it has
absolutely nothing to do with the White
House Press Secretary not being able to
speak on a major matter of campaign
Finance it's totally bogus Zeke Miller
the reporter there understands it's
totally bogus Zeke was actually a friend
of mine his friend of mine from college
and uh he's a really good reporter and
he's not he's not a right-wing
conservative by any stretch of the
imagination and he's not a total
far-left liberal he's just a good
reporter and you hear him just dogging
her on this he says the Hatch Act that's
your answer
um you sure that's your story and you're
sticking to yes we're covered by the we
know we're not saying a word about how
the second largest donor to the
Democrats last cycle is maybe the
biggest Financial scammer in American
history nope nope can't talk about that
can't sorry nothing to say here move
along Move Along Move Along
conservatives should be dogged about
this we should keep trailing them on
this this should become a big issue tie
them up in court tie them up in the
Press if we can don't don't let this go
allow the example of Gibson's Bakery
over in Oberlin
to inspire you took six years for
justice to be done everyone thought the
deck is so stacked against this Bakery
the University or this college rather
thought there's no way we've got
billions of dollars we're just going to
be able to squash this little little
family shop
that's not what happens if you just
fight back if you just remain persistent
if when you get little bits of political
power you wield that political power we
can
take back a lot of our country take back
a lot of our culture and beat the libs
now I gotta go catch this flight to
Phoenix
you can catch me over there later today
at TP USA so no member block today it
kills me I know that's part of my
favorite probably my favorite time of
the whole day uh definitely up there
it's when I see my sweet little kids
kiss them good night spend time with my
family and then when I spend time with
you on the member block so join become a
daily wire plus member we will see you
tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]